l'intelligence artificielle fait souvent
les manchettes si cette technologie
accomplit des prouesses elle renferme
une part d'ombre elle est si énergivore
qu'elle laisse une importante empreinte
écologique
selon certaines estimations développer
un logiciel d'intelligence artificielle
générer autant d'émissions carbone que 5
voitures à essence de leur fabrication à
leur fin de vie
[Musique]
mais pourquoi le stèle une empreinte si
importante
l'intelligence artificielle est une
machine qui imite l'intelligence humaine
à la base elle se compose de réseau de
neurones artificielle chaque neurone
représentant un calcul mathématique
pour apprendre l'intelligence
artificielle doit lire analyser une
quantité phénoménale de données
et sa vitesse d'apprentissage est très
lente
[Musique]
tellement lente que pour améliorer sa
précision 1%, les ordinateurs doivent
fonctionner et calculer pendant des
jours voir des semaines
cela demande évidemment beaucoup
d'électricité
les données nécessaires à son
apprentissage sont emmagasinés dans des
centres remplis de serveurs lorsqu'ils
sont alimentés par les énergies fossiles
ces sites produisent d'importantes
quantités de CO2
prenons l'exemple du GP3 l'un des plus
grands logiciels de langage une
intelligence artificielle capable
d'écrire entre autres des articles de
presse et même de la poésie
selon une étude danoise son
apprentissage a nécessité autant
d'énergie que la consommation de 126
foyers en un an
mais tout n'est pas sombre aujourd'hui
pour évaluer la performance d'une
intelligence artificielle on tient
compte de son empreinte écologique
pour diminuer les émissions il faut
d'abord pouvoir les estimer c'est ce que
permet de logiciel code carbone
l'algorithme utilise lui-même
l'intelligence artificielle pour mesurer
l'impact écologique d'un programme mais
en plus le code carbone fournit des
conseils pour rendre les calculs
informatiques plus efficaces et surtout
moins polluants
initiatives permettent aux chercheurs
d'utiliser des modèles d'intelligence
artificielle qui n'ont plus à
s'entraîner du recyclage technologique
nouveau genre
[Musique]